ahora veamos un ejemplo de cómo se
aplica la regla del cociente de la
derivada que les repito a mí no me
parece que sea una nueva regla más bien
es una regla que se deriva de la regla
del producto si se acuerdan por aquí la
teníamos aquí esta de la regla del
producto sacábamos cuál tenía que ser la
regla del cociente y ahora sí veamos un
ejemplo a ver por ejemplo calculemos la
derivada con respecto de x de
de equis a ver a ver pero acabo de decir
que vamos a usar la regla del cociente
de la derivada que esto no tiene ningún
consciente pero lo podemos escribir como
un cociente o sea tan cliente de xy se
acuerdan de las igualdades
trigonométricas es ese 9 x entre coseno
de x entonces si escribimos a tangente
de x en esa forma ya podemos usar esta
regla de la derivada del cociente para
encontrar esta derivada entonces saber
derivada de tangente de x es lo mismo
que derivada con respecto de x de
seno de equis entre coseno de x
y esto siguiendo esta regla
efe prima de x o sea la derivada de lo
que está arriba y cuál es la derivada de
ese 9 x pues es simplemente conocer 9 x
por la función sin derivar que está
abajo o sea por coste de 9 x por 2 de 9
x menos la función que está arriba o sea
seno de x por la derivada de la función
que está abajo y la derivada la función
que está abajo con la derivada de coseno
de x pues es menos seno de x no entonces
función de arriba de 9 x derivada de la
función de abajo entonces ponemos el
seno de x y nos falta multiplicar por
menos uno porque es menos seno de x no
pero pues aquí hay un menos entonces
podemos aquí multiplicar menos por menos
si nos da más y esto dividido entre la
función de abajo al cuadrado o sea
coseno al cuadrado
ahora esto es coseno de x por cocina de
x o sea
con seno de x al cuadrado
que también lo podemos escribir como
coseno cuadrado de equis y lo mismo pasa
aquí o sea es cero por cero o sea
seno cuadrado de equis y haber otra vez
hay que regresar a nuestras igualdades
trigonométricas este es un lado de una
de las igualdades trigonométricas más
básicas y más famosas que hay con seno
al cuadrado de x más seno cuadrado de x
es igual a 1 entonces lo que nos queda
es uno entre coseno de x al cuadrado que
a su vez se puede escribir como
1 / costero de x al cuadrado y ya que
estamos metidos con todo esto de las
igualdades trigonométricas a ver
rápidamente digan esto que es igual pues
1 entre cosas 9 x es la secante de x
entonces aquí nos queda secante de x al
cuadrado
que también la podemos describir como
secante cuadrado de x
listo esto es la derivada con respecto
de x de la tangente de x y lo único que
hicimos fue escribir a tangente de x
como un cociente y aplicar la regla del
cociente y le repito la regla del
cociente se deriva directamente de la
regla del producto